hallo manuel kari hier ist es ja ganz
dunkel sie überhaupt nichts wo sind wir
denn hier
wir sind glaube ich in unserem podcast
studio ich warte mal wo ist hier das
licht das ist also unser neues das ist
unser neues podcast studio hier werden
wir in zukunft jede woche den easy
german podcast aufzeichnen die easy
german podcast mal was ist denn das naja
also weißt du was ein podcast ist ja
also da kann man was hören und dann
reden menschen in einer genau in zukunft
werdet ihr uns nicht nur jede woche auf
youtube sehen können in zwei
unterschiedlichen videos sondern auch
jede woche zu hören können und dann
werden wir ein bisschen mehr zeit haben
mit euch zu sprechen
und warum machen wir machen diesen
podcast eigentlich aus dem gleichen
grund warum wir auch die videos machen
weil wir glauben dass es wichtig ist
wenn man eine sprache lernt sie auch
wirklich zu erleben in unseren videos
sprechen wir mit richtigen echten
menschen über echte themen auf der
straße und in unserem podcast werden wir
uns miteinander unterhalten und mit
einigen anderen leuten auch über echte
themen auch in einer normalen
geschwindigkeit und so könnt ihr euch
mit der sprache umgeben und richtig in
die deutsche sprache eintauchen und zwar
auch dann wenn ihr gar keine videos
gerade schauen könnt wurden zb na also
zum beispiel könnte man ein podcast
hören beim zähneputzen morgens wenn man
aufsteht oder beim einkaufen oder wenn
vielleicht beim programmieren kann man
da auch kann man da auch podcasts hören
wenn man ein genie ist und sich auf
beides fokussieren können natürlich
schon eine frage die ich mir jetzt immer
gestellt habe als wir darüber geredet
haben dass wir den podcast machen ist
unsere videos sind ja dafür bekannt dass
man etwas hören kann aber auch dass man
mit lesen kann wie ihr wisst haben wir
immer untertitel auf deutsch auf
englisch und dadurch könnte eben der
sprache sehr gut folgen
wie macht man das denn jetzt in dem
podcast ist das wirklich genauso
nützlich
ich glaube zum einen kommt es erst mal
ja darauf an sich wirklich mit der
sprache zu umgeben selbst wenn man nicht
jedes wort versteht ist es glaube ich
nützlich einfach zuzuhören und ihr könnt
egal eigentlich welche podcast app ihr
benutzt uns ja zum beispiel auch
langsamer machen und uns einfach
langsamer zu hören
also ich spreche dann viel langsamer als
normal noch langsamer als du es eh schon
tust kann man bei youtube übrigens auch
maria stimmt das hört sich manchmal sehr
witzig anja dann klingt man immer ein
bisschen besoffen und zusätzlich haben
wir aber ein paar besondere angebote und
zwar werden wir beim podcast ein
komplettes transkript zur verfügung
stellen so dass man theoretisch die
gesamte folge nicht nur hören sondern
auch mitlesen kann
und darauf freue ich mich besonders wir
haben uns etwas ausgedacht das nennen
wir vokabel hilfe und zwar wird es so
funktionieren gehört den podcast und es
gibt vielleicht ein wort oder ein
ausdruck den ihr nicht versteht aber den
ihr gerne genau wissen möchte was
bedeutet dass dann könnt ihr in dem
moment einfach das handy aus der
hosentasche ziehen und in eurer podcast
app schauen und dort ist eine liste mit
den zehn wichtigsten wörtern und
vokabeln aus der aktuellen minute und
jede minute wechselt dieses bild und
dann sind wieder die nächsten zehn
wörter und begriffe aus der aktuellen
minute und so kann man tatsächlich
jederzeit wenn man wirklich wissen
möchte was hat dieses wort jetzt
bedeutet kurz auf sein handy schauen die
übersetzung nach
und es dann wieder wegstecken und diesen
beiden dinge das transkript und die
vokabel hilfe die werden wir jetzt in
den ersten episoden mal allen zur
verfügung stellen dass sie sich das
anschauen könnte das ihr euch das
anschauen könnt und langfristig werden
dass zwei features sein die wir unseren
patches unseren easy german mitgliedern
zur verfügung stellen das heißt genau
wie bei unseren videos glauben wir daran
dass es wichtig ist dass wir die unsere
ressourcen umsonst zur verfügung stellen
für euch und dass jeder zugang dazu hat
gleichzeitig werden die mitglieder von
uns die uns unterstützen etwas
zusätzliches erhalten und die können
dann etwas tiefer in den content
eintauchen kann etwas mehr mit dem
material lernen und an diese mitglieder
sind wir wirklich dankbar denn die
ermöglichen uns wirklich das zu machen
was machen wir da eigentlich
wir haben eine ganze menge vor wir
wollen ähnlich wie bei den videos jede
woche ein bestimmtes thema besprechen
da könnt ihr euch überraschen lassen was
jeweils das aktuelle thema sein wird
aber wir haben auch ein paar andere
segmente speziell auch für deutschlerner
verbreitet zb haben wir jede woche für
euch einen ausdruck der woche da werden
wir euch also neue interessante vokabeln
vermitteln wir haben auch lieder für
euch manuel hat unglaublich viele
deutsche bands die er gerne mag und über
die er unbedingt mit euch reden möchte
denn er hat das gefühl dass die noch gar
nicht so bekannt sind wie sie bekannt
sein sollten habe ich das richtig
aufgefasst genau ich frage immer meine
freunde die deutsch lernen kennst du die
ärzte und dann sagen hinein nicht so wie
du kennst die ärzte nicht deswegen wird
es dieses segment geben die ärzte kennt
hier nun wirklich jeder habe ich musste
christin kennt leider nicht jeder
außerdem haben wir noch immer ein paar
knifflige fragen und wir haben auch
witze für euch auch janne schrittweise
mit einer kleinen philosophischen ecke
ja wenn ihr jetzt unbedingt sagt diesen
podcast den möchte ich hören ich möchte
ab jetzt jede woche manuel und kari und
die amish zu hören während ich meine
wohnung putzen dann könnt ihr jetzt mal
auf eure hände auf eure handys schauen
dort in euren podcasts nach usedom
suchen wir sind auf allen gängigen
podcast portalen in allen apps werdet
ihr den podcast finden und könnt dort
den podcast abonnieren
jede woche eine neue episode bekommen
und zwar wann immer dienstags jeden
dienstag findet ihr die neue episode von
unserem podcast
was muss man noch wissen ganz wichtig
ihr findet uns zwar überall dort wo es
podcast gibt aber die vokabel hilfe
funktioniert nicht leider mit allen
podcast apps am besten schaut ihr auf
unserer webseite easy german punkt fm
und dort erklären wir euch genau und
zeigen genau welche apps auf android und
auf dem iphone
dieses feature unterstützen gut dann
sehen wir uns jetzt in eurer podcast app
oder bei easy germany
wir freuen uns auf euch und danke für zu
sehen bis bald 22
[Musik]